Helen Hayes Ingrid Bergman Maggie Smith
Meryl Streep these are for gifted women
who have won Oscars for Best Actress and
Best Supporting Actress last year
another name was added to that circle
ladies and gentlemen miss Jessica Lange
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
there are a lot of definitions of acting
but none of them fully catch the elusive
enchantment of a great performance
there's only one way to do that and it's
what these five actors have done they've
given the performance here are the
nominees for Best Actor in a leading
role Nicolas Cage and leaving Las Vegas
Richard Dreyfuss in mr. Holland's Opus
Anthony Hopkins and Nixon
Sean Penn and dead man walking
Massimo crazy from the postman
and the Oscar is awarded to Nicolas Cage
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh boy oh boy three and a half million
dollar budget some 16 millimeter film
stock thrown in I'm holding one of these
I have got to thank the members of the
Academy for this for including me in
this group of super talents and and for
helping me blur the line between art and
commerce with this award I well I I know
it's not hip to say it but I just love
acting and I hope that I hope that there
will be more encouragement for
alternative movies where we can
experiment and fast forward into the
future of acting let me thank the
awesome multi-talented Mike Figgis my
incredible my incredible amazing co-star
Elizabeth Shue I am I am going to share
this award with both of you and the late
John O'Brien whose spirit moved me so
much
Tony Dingman Annie Stuart the producers
Annie Stuart Stuart Regan Regan everyone
at mga mgm/ua I'm sorry and Lumiere I'd
like to thank ed LeMond oh my colleagues
Jerry Harrington Jeff Levine Richard
Lovett and everyone in my family my
gorgeous wife Patricia and I just
finally want to say hi West in its daddy
I love you thank you
[Applause]
[Music]